point d'honneur à le faire correctement
première pierre pour ce bâtiment qui
offrira dès la rentrée prochaine 180
places d'hébergement aux élèves du lycée
militaire de saint-cyr coût de ces
travaux est 7 millions d'euros ils sont
entièrement financés par le plan lycée
lancé par la secrétaire d'état auprès de
la ministre des armées
nous avons besoin de conserver ses
infrastructures en bon état nous avons
pérennisé celis et pérenniser
l'enseignement qu'il y avait à
l'intérieur de ces lycées et même
augmenter les filières possibles et donc
nous avions besoin de travailler sur les
infrastructures dont certaines étaient
sont très vieillissante et nécessite
vraiment des améliorations ce bâtiment
modulaire de 2000 m² et la première
infrastructure nouvelle qui voit le jour
dans le cadre du plan lycée évolutif il
accueillera dans un second temps des
salles de cours
donc on a en charge ses travaux et par
la suite d'autres travaux qui en
découlent dont notamment la rénovation
d'un bâtiment complet de chambre et
les sanitaires de tous les internats
dans le bâtiment ancien qui date de
l'après guerre la france compte sur son
territoire si l'établissement de la
défense
plus de 110 millions d'euros vont ainsi
être consacrés jusqu'en 2025 à
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
et de vie des élèves et des enseignants